my good the best of my life when i was
young free
sexy agile fling my legs over my
shoulders was all between the ages or
twenty
because because of your nose
you don't you don't have the youth and
you don't have the purity at 30. it's
gone so it's you don't have what men
value okay as i said
first of all right now uh 20 years old a
girl cannot have purity anymore because
they probably lose their virginity when
they 12. but let's forget about it so if
that the point that means that every
woman that uh has child a child before
oh yes relationship important
relationship before could not have a
husband later and i saw a lot of people
that actually had child
before and after they get married or
whatever so what do you mean that demand
they actually you know
wifey air is a i don't know it's a bum
like
a bum well men don't i don't care about
your job
like you could like you could do nothing
and like men do not give a [ __ ] like
because you said earlier like i make
money and i'm like well not to men
that's like a shoe collection to women
like if a guy if a guy says if a guy
says oh i have a cool shoe collection
we're like oh that's cool but then we
keep moving that's how men feel about
work
okay so they like
they'd prefer a girl that like does
nothing so she can like hang out with
them and like don't on them
honestly speaking um me myself because
we're talking about what are men
expecting from our women but we're not
talking about what are women expecting
is expecting from a man and then because
we always hear it
because we always
no no did you did you in my point of
like you think like what we're talking
about now is just a part of the you know
man in the world which is probably the
majority but doesn't mean that is the
totality guys
so
okay anyway it's fine yeah we can we can
keep saying that's the majority and i'm
i'm i'm fine with that cool all right
but again that's who said that but we
want that majority a man going out and
saying okay cool i want to go and find a
virgin yeah
and we're gonna go and find this virgin
it's the same way you're saying
oh i'm gonna be this exception and i
will find that guy who wants me
no but you're saying
no no no no no you didn't get my point i
don't give a [ __ ] to find the men who
evaluate me because i know i know about
my value i don't need a man to recognize
my value i don't give a [ __ ] if i gonna
find him cool
but you if i don't i can stand on my own
i'm paying my bills
i got a job well i do what do i need a
man for okay do you have sex but that's
fine
i can still have sex i have a question i
have a question for you how do you
determine what your value is right i
told you i told you a woman for me is an
independent woman who can stand by his
own can pay air bills he has the
maturity to understand even when is the
right time to have a children because
everyone can have a child anytime just
you know and then those people it's also
about how we have our you know what kind
of parent we are so it's not just about
having eggs because honestly i prefer
women that stay without children instead
that someone that who doesn't deal with
properly so question who is that
valuable to
what you just listed who is that
valuable to you mean who who yeah who is
that valuable to
what you just myself i don't care about
other people's opinion okay so i i need
to like that's just to people that i
should like
worry about god and myself
not about other men you don't care not
about no that's all no no no
okay so
so i just want to clarify so you don't
care what men want and and the way you
determine your value is what you say
yeah isn't that a bit narcissistic no
he's not
because you're not only because you only
care about yourself and not what anyone
else wants no listen to the point i
don't i didn't say it just about myself
just about the people that actually is
in in my small circle which is different
because when someone comes inside my
circles they actually understand my
value i don't need to explain to them
so that's the point
the other point obviously i don't i
don't give a [ __ ] about any uh not
offense but really about people that is
not in my small circle so
like okay i'm not vulnerable okay cool
like peace like i'm gonna come back to
my life i'm gonna go to work tomorrow
i'm gonna keep paying my bills and you
know what i mean like
okay so you you basically turn into that
like this is what girls do though like
women turn into the men they want to
marry so if you're looking for a guy
like all the things you i'm not looking
for a guy no no no i know you're not i'm
saying but like typically i'm saying in
general i don't know you personally but
i'm saying in general when women become
the men they want to marry so they
become all the things that like men want
because what she just described that's
the mat like that's the man i would date
but it's not women it's not what men
want yeah like a guy that's independent
that pays his bills that goes like he
gets the back i'm like sign me up but to
a man that's like that's that's a red
flag we said men don't care what a woman
about her career yeah that's what i said
so then if she's making money getting
her bag whatever whatever a man wouldn't
care no no no
so then her values so then a man will
approach her then a man will want her a
man because he can walk into tesco and
see an attractive girl at the till i
agree he wants to change her life
a woman will not walk into tesco see an
attractive man that's what you think i i
i guess
that's fair that's not the total
it's not the totality i had i've been in
relationship with men they're honestly
less than me they had absolutely nothing
and where are they now
what does it mean that i like what about
other other men that are six foot and
they i don't know the billionaire they
anyway
go like you know if you if you meet a
billionaire you're dating a billionaire
you fumble the bag
listen
i actually i actually like com comparing
i probably had more relationship with
people that you know are
less rich than someone that i probably
didn't give a chance i didn't give a
chance to them right so it's not so
you've dated like broke guys is what
you're saying i had some not broken like
so
i wasn't checking them out
i'm not doing it still now do you think
you attract feminine guys because you're
more masculine uh
no i wouldn't say feminine
honestly just people with balls which is
different it's not about being
yeah it's not about being feminist about
be very confident because when you're
standing next to me because i think i'm
tough i got strong personality you need
both honestly
someone else who prefer a young lady who
doesn't work who can be manipulated and
can be you know control because you are
strong in the relationship i need a man
it doesn't really is a partnership like
we are together we strong in the same
way when a man is looking for a younger
lady which is virgin who doesn't work he
probably earned less than me is because
they need to feel like they are the
strongest one they controlling
they controlling
they taking the power in the
relationship
you're just deciding what you believe
men no that's my point of view yeah you
will decide
i'm not deciding i'm expressing my point
of view of you no you were deciding
where you said i'm not deciding you are
you said men go for younger women
because they feel they're going to
control them and manipulate them
whatever what if men said that about
women they look so stupid if they're
like like women like rich guys because
they want to manipulate and control them
people be like